Salut, c’est Juliette !
Aujourd’hui, je voulais vous raconter
l’histoire de Solène.
Solène, elle souffre d’anorexie
depuis qu’elle a 13 ans,
et aujourd'hui, elle en a 18.
Il y a un an, je suis tombée sur
une de ses vidéos TikTok
où elle racontait son quotidien.
Là, tu es en train de me vexer, là.
Là, tu es en train de me vexer.
Me dis pas des trucs comme ça.
C'était pendant le confinement, et du coup,
on s’était rencontrées via Zoom.
Je peux juste te demander de décaler
la caméra ou toi un tout petit peu.
On a fait une interview
pour Brut ensemble
où elle nous racontait un peu sa maladie.
Elle me racontait les moments difficiles
qu’elle avait traversés avec l’anorexie,
mais à ce moment-là,
elle allait beaucoup mieux.
Quand la vidéo est sortie,
elle a touché énormément de personnes,
et Solène a reçu des centaines
de messages de soutien.
On est restées en contact
toute l’année,
mais malheureusement, en mai 2021,
Solène a rechuté.
Et en juin 2021,
elle est repartie à l'hôpital
pour une troisième fois.
Elle porte une sonde
depuis 7 mois
et ne peut qu'aller en cours
deux fois par semaine,
parce que sinon,
elle est trop fatiguée.
On ne s’est encore
jamais rencontrées,
parce que quand on s’était parlé,
c’était via Zoom et téléphone.
Donc pour cette vidéo,
je suis allée rencontrer Solène
pour la première fois.
Hey !
Ça fait trop plaisir
de te voir en vrai !
- Mais c’est ouf !
C’est trop cool.
Attends, je fais juste mes réglages
de mise au point.
OK ! Du coup, là,
je suis avec Solène,
je suis dans le miroir
derrière toi.
Et là, on est en train de se dire
que la dernière fois qu’on a fait la vidéo,
c’était quand, du coup ?
- Le 19 février 2021.
- Et aujourd'hui, on est quoi ?
- On est le 16 février 2022.
Et là, on voit toutes les réactions
de mes amies qui avaient vu
la vidéo Brut.
J’ai changé en un an !
- Là, tu te sens comment ?
- Hmm…
- Comparé à il y a un an ?
- Bah, forcément,
moins bien.
Déjà, physiquement,
je suis plus la même.
Ça fait depuis que j’ai 13 ans
que je souffre de cette maladie,
et j’en ai 18 aujourd'hui.
J’ai eu un traumatisme
quand j’avais 12 ans
et je pense que c’est le fait
de ne pas avoir contrôlé ce traumatisme
qui a fait que j’ai voulu contrôler
quelque chose d’autre
dans ma vie quotidienne,
et ça a été la nourriture.
Donc là, bah, y a mon petit café,
mon petit espresso.
Mais, par exemple, le gâteau,
bah, je ne vais pas le manger.
C'est un truc, genre,
même le sucre et tout,
je suis en mode :
"No, thanks!"
Ce qui est dur, c’est que
notre propre médicament,
bah, c’est nous-mêmes.
Comme nous-mêmes, on est
notre propre ennemi dans la maladie.
C’est comme si
on était deux personnes.
Donc il y a la Solène
qui est "normale", entre guillemets,
qui est pas malade,
qui a envie de vivre, qui a envie de sortir,
d’aller mieux, de faire ses études,
après, d’être psychologue
ou d’être professeure.
Ça, je ne sais pas encore.
Et la Solène qui est malade,
qui me bouffe littéralement, en fait,
de l'intérieur comme de l'extérieur,
qui est constamment là,
et qui prend plus parti
dans ma vie que l’autre Solène "normale",
entre guillemets, sans la maladie.
♫Si t’as l’impression que
personne te comprend ♫
♫ C’est parce que personne te comprend ♫
Je fais des tiktoks,
et les gens me disent :
"Oh, t’es belle !"
"Oh, t’es magnifique !" etc.
Et du coup, après,
y a d’autres commentaires qui font :
"Mais non, mais en fait,
il faut pas que tu lui dises ça,
parce qu’après,
elle va croire qu’elle est belle.
Et du coup, elle va continuer
dans cette continuité
d'être mal et d'être maigre, et d'être squelettique, et c’est moche."
Parfois, il y a des filles
qui mettent en valeur leur maigreur.
Moi, je ne le fais pas.
Enfin, genre…
Ou alors, je le fais inconsciemment,
mais enfin,
c’est juste que moi, je suis une fille…
Donc cette Solène "normale",
entre guillemets,
a toujours aimé être coquette,
se maquiller, être bien apprêtée.
J’ai toujours gardé ça,
même en étant malade,
et c’est vrai que parfois,
justement, bah,
ça peut être pris comme
une glamourisation
de l’anorexie,
alors qu’au final, pas du tout.
C’est juste prendre soin de soi,
même dans le plus mal.
C’est un combat de tous les jours
sur comment manger,
combien de calories,
combien d’heures je fais de sport,
au lieu de travailler,
au lieu de sortir avec mes potes.
C’est être détachée du monde,
c’est perdre la vie, en fait.
Enfin, c’est perdre toute vie normale.
Est-ce que tu prends une petite courgette,
ou je sais pas quoi ?
- Ouais.
T’as pris tes médocs ?
OK, très bien.
C’est parfait.
Il y a des troubles physiques,
clairs, pour le malade.
Il y a des souffrances physiques
pour le malade…
*sonnerie*
Et il y a… Pardon.
Et c’est la psychiatre de Solène.
Je peux ?
- Oui, évidemment.
Allô ? Bonjour, docteure.
Avant,
voilà, j'étais dans :
"Elle est à l'hôpital, elle est à la clinique,
elle va sortir, elle sera guérie."
Et j’ai mis beaucoup,
beaucoup, beaucoup de temps
à comprendre que cette maladie
était extrêmement sournoise,
qu’elle était imprévisible.
C’est une maladie psychiatrique,
et on n’en sait pas grand-chose.
On voit les conséquences,
on peut voir même un peu les causes,
mais après, il y a la réalité de cette maladie.
Et ça, c’est… Waouh.
Difficile.
Là, genre, je vais prendre des courgettes.
Et genre, il y a deux semaines, bah,
j’en prenais pas,
parce que j’avais “peur” de ça,
entre guillemets.
Alors qu’en fait, bah, c’est rien.
C’est juste, genre,
bah, un légume qui est bon pour toi
et tout, et genre,
c’est juste le fait de rajouter
quelque chose dans mon alimentation.
Je pensais que j’allais grossir,
alors qu’en fait, pas du tout.
Et pour les proches,
c’est compliqué aussi, parce que
ils voient que j’avance
mais très, très doucement.
Qu’est-ce qu’il y a ?
Je te mets un couteau ?
Euh, ouais, s’il te plaît.
Enfin... Non, j’en ai pas besoin aujourd'hui.
Je te mets pas de couteau ?
Non.
Tiens, ça, c’est… Tu sais où c’est ?
- Ouais.
Elle n'est pas drôle, notre vie.
C’est, euh…
À aucun...
À aucun membre de la famille.
Tout le monde est…
On est tous
prisonniers et victimes
de cette maladie.
C’est difficile de se réjouir de…
Même une fête de famille
ou un repas de Noël,
c’est compliqué.
Voyager, c’est compliqué.
Voilà.
Tout est difficile.
Hop.
En fait, c’est la machine,
et dedans, vous avez…
Vous devez accrocher
ça.
Solène porte une sonde.
C’est un petit tuyau
qui passe du nez jusqu'à l'estomac,
et ça lui permet de s’alimenter
de manière régulière et efficace.
Et là, il y a le sac à dos pour l'école,
et du coup, bah, je mets juste ça.
Alors, j’ai lui, j’ai celui des cours,
et aussi, j’ai mon déjeuner, du coup.
J’ai trois sacs, et du coup,
tout le monde est en mode :
"Mais qu'est-ce que tu fais
avec trois sacs ?
On dirait que tu déménages !"
Ah non, non, c’est juste ça, ça, ça…
Du coup, je dois expliquer, et du coup,
parfois, c’est un peu gênant,
mais ça va.
Elle a toujours des moments de joie,
de bonne humeur, de gaieté…
Mais,
vous savez, cette espèce
de petite impulsion d’insouciance
qu’on devrait avoir quand on a 18 ans,
elle ne l’a pas du tout.
Ce côté :
"Je fais ce que je veux, je m’en fous de la vie. C’est sympa.
Oh, mes parents, je les emmerde.
Je rentrerai quand je voudrai."
Des trucs que tous les ados font,
qui mettent les parents en rage,
mais qui n'arriveront pas
ou qui ne se produisent pas ici.
En fait, genre, je me dis
que la bouteille en entier, c’est trop, alors que...
"Duh !" C’est juste une soupe.
Tu les manges crues, tes courgettes ?
- Ouais.
Je sais que ce n'est pas très bien pour mon ventre, mais, euh…
Mais ça se mange cru, normalement ?
Ça se mange cuit !
- Ça peut se manger cru et cuit.
Ah, ouais.
- En fait, j’ai plus de mal à m’imaginer manger des légumes cuits que crus.
Parce que pour moi, cuits, bah, du coup,
tu dois rajouter des matières grasses et tout.
Bah, non, trop pas.
Juste, tu mets ça dans la poêle,
et si c’est une poêle anti-adhésive, normalement,
t’as même pas besoin de matières grasses.
Ça cuit tout seul !
- Ouais…
Bah, ça sera meilleur, surtout.
Et ouais, pour ton ventre,
peut-être meilleur quand c'est cuit, quoi.
- Mais, ouais.
Je sais pas,
dans ma tête, c’est comme ça.
En vrai, tant que tu manges la courgette,
c’est le principal.
Je redécouvre aussi à manger littéralement,
et genre,
bah, ça fait bizarre au début.
Au début, je me sens coupable de me dire que c’est bon.
Je me sens pas de m’autoriser à manger,
alors qu’en fait, bah, c’est juste normal, en fait.
Mais je suis fière d’avoir,
bah,
d’en être arrivée au moins là.
Comment est la soupe ?
- La soupe est bonne !
À chaque fois que je reprenais du poids
et que je recommençais à manger,
c'était pour les autres,
pour ma famille, pour mes amis.
Et en fait, je me suis rendu compte que
c'était bien, hein.
C'était bien,
mais ce n'était pas suffisant.
Qu’à chaque fois, en fait,
je rechutais parce que, justement,
la maladie me disait que
je ne méritais pas de guérir.
Et on sait que parfois, elle essaie,
mais, enfin bon,
elle peut finir en larmes, parce que...
Pour, aussi, nous faire plaisir et nous soulager,
elle va finir un bol de soupe
qu’elle s’était préparé
et qui était peut-être
un peu important, euh…
Voilà, moi, je l’ai vue pleurer à la fin d’un dîner qui était très léger, malgré tout.
Et elle finit le dîner en larmes
et elle quitte la table,
elle va dans sa chambre, et elle pleure,
mais vraiment des sanglots de douleur.
- Parce qu’elle trouve qu’elle a trop mangé ?
Parce qu’elle trouve qu’elle a trop mangé.
Voilà.
Donc, c'est…
Enfin, c’est assez incroyable
de vivre ça.
Je fais souffrir mes proches, énormément.
Je sais que, bah,
forcément, je me fais souffrir
moi-même aussi.
Mais, pourtant, je continue à faire
les choses qu’il ne faut pas faire.
J’ai l’impression que
ça m’apporte quelque chose,
mais, en fait, c’est juste éphémère.
C’est juste...
C’est faux, en fait, c’est juste...
un faux-semblant de quelque chose.
En fait, Solène,
c'est pas la seule à vivre ce qu’elle vit.
La semaine passée,
j’ai lancé une messagerie
pour avoir un peu vos retours
et vos expériences sur cette maladie,
et vous avez été très,
très nombreux à me répondre.
"Jusqu’au jour où mon père m’a dit que je ressemble à un squelette.
Et je me rappelle de cette phrase qui m’a
choqué et qui m'a fait un peu prendre conscience des choses."
C’est maintenant la troisième fois
que je lance une messagerie
pour une de mes vidéos,
et j’ai jamais reçu autant
de messages en une journée.
“J’ai été malade
pendant plus d’une dizaine d’années,
et je pense d’ailleurs que
c’est une maladie qui fera partie de moi
toute ma vie."
Comme Solène, beaucoup de vos messages témoignent de ce paradoxe de l’anorexie.
On sait qu’on doit guérir, mais en même temps, on n'en a pas vraiment envie.
Depuis notre dernière rencontre,
Solène a pu finalement retirer sa sonde.
C’est un énorme pas en avant.
Par contre, ça présente
plein de nouveaux problèmes,
notamment le fait qu'elle doit
prendre du poids toute seule,
sans l’aide de sa sonde qui
lui apportait environ 700 calories par jour.
Coucou !
Hello ! Ça va ?
Ça va, et toi ?
Du coup, on est “back” avec Solène.
- Yes ! Coucou !
Solène, c’est quoi la différence
aujourd'hui qu'il y a 2 semaines ?
- J’ai plus ma sonde !
Et ça fait comment ?
- Bah, ça fait du bien !
Je suis libre de moi-même, donc tant mieux !
Viens, ma doudouce.
On va de ce côté-là, en fait.
Allez, ma Céleste !
Céleste !
Allô ?
Mon espoir pour le futur, c’est que le processus dans lequel Solène, à mes yeux,
est en train d'entrer,
va être une espèce de cercle vertueux.
Parce qu’on ne vit pas toute
sa vie avec une sonde,
parce que on ne vit pas toute
sa vie avec sa mère,
parce qu’on ne vit pas toute sa vie à avoir une activité deux jours par semaine,
et le reste du temps, seule,
dans une solitude atroce pour une jeune fille
de son âge, dans sa chambre.
Voilà.
Faut que tu prévoies...
Des légumes.
Skyr.
Ouais,
Aller mieux, c’est ne pas être
focalisé sur la maladie,
plus être focalisé sur
ce que l’on veut vraiment.
La Solène, la vraie Solène.
J'essaie d’aller mieux,
mais en même temps,
j’ai envie de perdre du poids encore.
J’ai encore du chemin à faire,
mais je sais que je vais y arriver,
parce que je suis bien entourée.
Si cette vidéo vous a intéressé, vous pouvez vous abonner à notre chaîne YouTube
pour voir d’autres reportages.
Et n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer
un message sur Instagram
si vous avez d’autres idées de sujets,
de choses qui vous tiennent à cœur.